if you haven't seen the end credits of
picardo season 3 turn this video off now
because there are spoilers ahead
[Music]
I just want to make a quick video
because I've just seen the end credit to
Picard season three and I have to admit
I don't really know what to think about
it
yes in one respect it sets up Legacy and
we want Star Trek Legacy us trekkies are
desperate for Star Trek Legacy
but on the other hand
they made the Titan a
into the new Enterprise
I don't like that I'm not I'm not a big
fan of that
the Enterprise is normally the flagship
and it's supposed to be the most
advanced the most capable vessel in the
fleet
or at least at the point of being
commissioned
I mean the Enterprise a the Constitution
class was the most capable vessel in the
fleet at the start of the movie and
motion picture it got upgraded for new
shields which made it even more capable
but obviously they know the vessels over
time you know replace it the Excelsior
was more capable et cetera but at the
point of commission and it should be the
most advanced vessel in the flea
and for the very early episodes in
Picard season 3 they showed us
repeatedly that this vessel isn't
particularly capable
um it got its ass handed to it by the
shrike and you know Captain Shaw
basically was like winner match with
this without even firing a shot we're
not much of this and run away so
I didn't like that but the other thing
is about the titano becoming the
Enterprise the Titan a is already a
brilliant name they didn't need to do
that
why would they
you build a new Enterprise you don't
rename an already famous ship I mean
this is why it's called the Titan a
apparently because only famous ships get
the designation when there's a new one
so it's already a famous ship it was
already Riker's ship why rename it to
Enterprise G it doesn't make sense to me
and I kind of dislike that
the other big problem
which isn't really a problem but I
really can't decide what to feel about
it is Q returning
so he said look John Luke's trial is
over but now it's your turn jack
and you know I'm not going to say that
look
the queue's dead so we shouldn't return
because Q is a time traveler so he says
in the end clip I wouldn't have thought
you'd think so you know Lenny linear
linear Lily
and it's true this could be an earlier
incarnation of cue the queue that we saw
die would have been a cue from a much
later time in in his time if you think
of it like that tell me why my stuff's
confusing but
he could be an earlier q i Am
I am a little conflicted because on one
hand I love John Delancey he's a
brilliant actor and I love him in
everything I've ever seen him in
um and him returning in Star Trek Legacy
even in small part brilliant
but on the other hand does it take
something away from season two the best
bit of season two was when Jean-Luc said
goodbye to Q said goodbye to the
character and now he's back
even though logically completely makes
sense and I'm keeping on board with it
trying to tell us you know you haven't
made a mistake or anything but I don't
know I'm confused by it and I'm not
really sure how to take it the other
thing is Terry metallis does seem to be
trying to fix everything and from the
early Picard Seasons they've ruined the
Borg in Picard season two and he has
fixed them they were brilliant just as
terrifying as they ever were absolutely
fantastic
and then he seems to now be trying to
fix the whole Q issue
because that was a little bit
disappointing in season two that we
didn't get a lot of the answers we were
hoping for from that
so
he's doing a pretty good job of fixing
it to be fair
but guys tell me what you think of this
season finale if you as confused as me a
little bit conflicted even or do you
just think nah so this this is setting
up Legacy and that's what we want and
Captain seven of nine oh
happy happy days if Jeri Ryan returns I
am a very very happy man I do think by
the way that they are setting this up
for Star Trek Legacy I think it'll take
a little while like
um basically bringing back strange new
worlds took a little while from when
they appeared in season two Discovery it
took a little bit of time tracks to get
the season going I think it's about two
even three years before it actually
appeared on the screens and I think
Legacy could take maybe that long
because I actually think Legacy has been
set up to possibly replace strange new
worlds but let's see I don't think that
decision has been made yet but possibly
I think they're only gonna have two live
action Star Trek series at a time
honestly so guys basically in the
comments tell me what you think of this
final credit scene I'd love to know
exactly what you're thinking if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
but that Bell notification it really
helps us out and as always I hope you
stay safe and I will see you next time
[Music]